es begann mit einer einfachen frage
wurde aber zu einer der größten
erfolgsgeschichten der silicon valley so
etwas wie der puls des internets es ist
eine serie für die freiheit wir glauben
dass der offene austausch von
informationen einen positiven globalen
einfluss haben kann ein megaphon für
politiker und ein roter teppich für
prominente die sich an ihre fans richten
um ein erfolgreiches startup zu gründen
braucht man zwei grundlegende dinge
großartige gründer und die passende
gelegenheit
flugpionierin williams mit biz stone und
dem ursprünglichen erfinder jack dorsey
von diese gelegenheit in twitter das auf
über 500 millionen registrierte nutzer
angewachsen ist die täglich über 55
millionen tweets schreiben
twitter ermöglicht es heim sich der welt
mitzuteilen
es war schon überall aber die reise
verlief nicht immer reibungslos vor
allem nicht für die drei
verantwortlichen von anfang an gab es im
unternehmen spannungen darüber wie wir
den enthusiasmus für dieses sehr
einfache produkt den umsatz und gewinn
umwandeln können
[Musik]
willkommen und hallo wir sind hier um
über twitter zu sprechen
das produkt ist ein kurzer informations
ausbruch von 140 zeichen oder weniger
genannt tweet twitter wurde von diesen
drei männern gegründet evan williams
bistum und jack dorsey im juli 2011
bewertete eine finanzierungsrunde das
unternehmen mit 8 milliarden dollar
ist verleger und transporter in der tech
szene
diese jungs haben etwas getan nicht weil
sie genau wussten wohin es führen würde
sondern weil sie dachten es sei an für
sich eine gute sache das sind meiner
meinung nach auf die wahren game changer
twitters mitbegründer ist der blogger
vorreiter evan williams das beste und
schlechteste sind zwei seiten derselben
zeit majors ist gründer und
geschäftsführender partner der
risikokapitalgesellschaft flatrate und
einer der frühen investoren von twitter
glaube er stur wenn es darum geht ideen
zu verfolgen die ihm am herzen liegen
aber was sich im laufe der zeit zu
schätzen gelernt habe ist dass er von
diesem glauben angetrieben wird als sohn
eines landwirts wurde williams 1972
geboren und wuchs auf der familien farm
in der nähe von clarks nebraska auf mac
arien kennt williams seit ende der 90er
jahre er war das dritte von vier kindern
und sein vater und dessen vater gingen
gerne auf die jagd und erwin ist veganer
also denke ich dass er sich so ein
bisschen eingefügt hat im ländlichen
nebraska wo er aufwuchs gibt es nicht
viele soja trinken die veganer auf den
benachbarten farmen somit war williams
leidenschaft nicht die landwirtschaft
sondern webdesign und programmierung
nach eineinhalb jahren an der
universität von nebraska brach sein
studium ab und trieb sich in
verschiedenen top jobs und startups
herum ich habe mein erstes unternehmen
1994 in der breisgau gegründet wozu ich
erst einmal erklären musste was das
internet überhaupt ist
malik ist gründer des tech-blogs gigaom
und schreibt seit über einem jahrzehnt
über das internet angeht nicht zur
schule um unternehmer zu werden entweder
man hat es oder man hat es nicht oder
und es scheint es einfach zu haben er
wurde damit geboren die fähigkeit
chancen zu erkennen ist angeboren sie
steckt in der dns und ich denke er in
gehört zu dieser gruppe mensch die es
einfach weiß
er nahm diesen unternehmergeist mit in
den westen in das mekka für
technikfreaks nach nordkalifornien
er hatte immer eine meinung dazu wie die
dinge besser werden könnten er war nie
zufrieden mit dem status quo
er hatte nie hemmungen uns mitzuteilen
was seiner meinung nach nicht
funktionierte und wie wir es besser
machen könnten
innerhalb eines jahres arbeitete
williams als unabhängige programmierer
zum schreiben von code für unternehmen
wie intel und hewlett packard
in san francisco tat er sich mit der
software unternehmerin meg harry hahn
zusammen
sie wurden ein paar und gründeten
gemeinsam das unternehmen pyra labs
das ist also mein schreibtisch sehr
unordentlich als ihr bei eurer gründeten
war das 1999 genau auf dem höhepunkt der
dotcom blase es war wirklich aufregend
zu der zeit in san francisco zu sein
relapse produkt war dazu gemacht
projekte zu verwalten den überblick über
aufgabenlisten zu behalten und kontakte
zu knüpfen ein kleines feature war ein
von williams erfundenes tool das die
aktualisierung eines persönlichen online
tagebuchs erleichterte dass damals
bekannt war als
dann entschied ein freund von uns
scherzhaft dass er
sondern blog nennen würde
williams ein neues produkt wenn es
wirklich gut mit branding und so er
sagte wir sollten es bleiben blogger.com
wurde zu einer sensation
ich konnte es kaum glauben jeden tag gab
es mehr besucher auf der webseite mehr
nutzer meldeten sich an ist es konnte
unmöglich so weiter gehen und am
nächsten tag waren es wieder mehr leute
journalist und berichtet über die
tech-branche niemand wusste wirklich was
blogs sind er hatte die idee dass er
eine einfache möglichkeit schaffen
wollte online ein artikel zu
veröffentlichen was kurzes über sein
leben zu schreiben und es zu
veröffentlichen es war ein neues
das bloggen bildete diese brillante
zusätzliche ebene dies ermöglichte nur
mit dem inhalt zu arbeiten nur mit den
bildern man musste nichts technisches
tun und so wurde das web wirklich zum
web für jedermann aber
die große idee des kleinen start ups war
nicht genug um es über wasser zu halten
tatsächlich traf es einen eisberg
der markt crash im jahre 2000 war eine
katastrophe für viele im silicon valley
die leute waren in panik dot com drohte
zu scheitern wir waren nicht darauf
vorbereitet wie schnell alles irgendwie
zusammenbrechen könnte uns ging das geld
aus ich verließ das unternehmen weil ich
enorm gestresst und gereizt war und
fünfstellige schulden hatte und er in
schloss dem laden und brachte die server
zurück in seine wohnung und kümmerte
sich zusammen um den sturm der post
dotcom-blase irgendwie zu überstehen die
post dotcom blase bei hässlichen san
francisco man hatte diese ganze gruppe
von leuten die dachten sie würden auf
den zug zum reichtum aufspringen und
dann mussten sie sich plötzlich nach
einem alternativen lebensweg umschauen
williams postete in seinem blog dass er
jetzt der einzige angestellte bei
blogger sei es gab einige ziemlich
düstere phasen und viele unternehmer
haben aufgegeben aber eben blieb dran
wenn man ein großer unternehmer ist muss
man bereit sein ein paar dinge
auszuprobieren und wenn man seine arbeit
nicht liebt wenn man auf heftigen
widerstand oder dummheit oder trägheit
stößt die die welt vor deine füße wirft
wird man aufgeben du wirst zwar nicht
durchhalten aber wenn du eine idee
wirklich liebst bist du davon überzeugt
dass du recht und der rest der welt
einfach unrecht hat so dass du einfach
weiter am ball bleibt und das wird es
sein dass dich letztendlich am leben
hält der ven williams leitete
blogger.com allein das unternehmen hatte
zu kämpfen und überlebte gerade so die
dot.com pleite er hatte nichts mehr
außer seiner idee als er einen anruf
eines branchenriesen erhielt er rief
seine ehemalige partnerin mccain an und
teilte ihr die neuigkeiten mit er fragte
sitzt du gerade und ich sagte ja nein
wirklich sitzt du gerade sagte er und
ich sagte ja ich sitze er sagte wir
haben gerade ein angebot von google
erhalten die summe des verkaufs wurde
nie bekannt gegeben das ist so als würde
man in der zweiten liga spielen und dann
rufen plötzlich die yankees sein und
sagen weißt du was ich möchte dass du
bei den play offs mitmachst google war
riesig sie waren cool und sie waren auf
dem vormarsch was ziemlich aufregend war
oder ich habe den perfekten zeitpunkt
erwischt google war auf dem vormarsch
und williams war dabei er begann mit der
entwicklung von blogger.com für den
explodierenden suchgiganten während
dieser zeit war sein zukünftiger
geschäftspartner bis zu 3.000 meilen
weit entfernt an der ostküste und
arbeitete als kreativdirektor an einer
konkurrierenden blocking website namens
xing.com
patrick ist autor und kommentator für
technologie und soziale medien
bistum ist ein interessanter typ für die
kinder lebt vom typ her ein rebell
ich glaube er ist sehr witzig und bissig
und macht gerne scherze stone sprang auf
dem blog in zug auf ihm gefiel aber kein
gas aus richtung nicht 2001 zucker unter
der leitung von schenker nach los
angeles und schrieb zwei bücher übers
bloggen auch stone erhielt einen anruf
und google und wurde eingestellt um dem
unternehmen bei der klum seiner
neuanschaffung blogger.com zu
unterstützen so trafen sich die beiden
zukünftigen geschäftspartner von twitter
zum allerersten mal 1999 evan und ich
waren im grunde genommen rivalen in
rivalisierenden firmen-events schickte
mir eine nachricht mit den worten wie
wäre es wenn du für mich arbeiten würde
das erste mal trafen wir uns also als er
mich vom flughafen abholte um mich zur
arbeit zu fahren aber ihre zeit im
unternehmen war begrenzt nach weniger
als zwei jahren verließ williams kugel
im oktober 2004 er hat ja noch nie für
jemanden oder in einem unternehmen
gearbeitet er ist ein erfinder ein
unternehmer er will die dinge genau dann
aufbauen können wenn sie ihm einfallen
beide 2004 schrieb williams einen
business plan für ein neues internet
startup namens audio ein podcasting
unternehmen das audios im internet
verbreiten und veröffentlichen sollte er
sammelte 5 milliarden dollar von einigen
der größten namen im bereich angel money
und risikokapital darunter google
geldgeber ron conway lotus gründer mit
kapoor und sein alter chef bei o'reilly
media tim o'reilly
nach dem essen mit blogger erfolgreich
war fiel es ihm relativ leicht angel
money und risikokapital gelder von der
idee zu überzeugen
das podcasting die neue generation des
bloggens werden würde
verließ google und schloss sich williams
bei audio an doch das junge unternehmen
erlitt einen vernichtenden schlag audio
prallte auf eine unsichtbare mauer
namens apple michaels hat 25.000 dollar
in orio investiert wir wollten podcasts
der breiten masse zugänglich machen und
eine woche nachdem ein check bekommen
hatte wurde apple plötzlich podcast auf
itunes sein wenn man podcast anbietet
muss dafür auch noch passende
wiedergabegeräte ist nicht mehr klar ob
man selbst damit überhaupt noch ein
geschäft machen konnte innerhalb von
sechs monaten nach gründung des podcast
dem unternehmens audiolith evan williams
erfolgsgeschichte auf dem silicon valley
einen dämpfer
[Musik]
audios web musik vertriebsunternehmen am
ende des jahres 2005 tot und jeder im
silicon valley wusste davon
ich hielt nicht viel von dir und ich
dachte so ein podcasting unternehmen
wäre irrelevant
während die aussichten des unternehmens
düster schienen tat sich am horizont ein
licht auf herbert jack dorsey im jahre
2005 führte durch sein eigenes startup
an ein selbst ernannter computerfreak
als kind war doch sie besessen von
karten
tapezierte sein ganzes zimmer mit karten
von nahverkehrssystemen
straßenkarten der stadtautobahn und als
seine familie schließlich am computer
anschaffte erkannte er dass er im grunde
genommen seine eigenen karten auf dem pc
zeichnen könnte er seine dort als
erwachsener verlagerte sich seine
besessenheit hin zur entwicklung von
software systemen für das sofortige
versenden von nachrichten
für notrufzentralen kuriere und taxis
das konzept war ganz einfach das ist das
was ich mache und jeder der daran
interessiert dass kann es in echtzeit
mitverfolgen
sie hatte jahrelang versucht das
potenzial eines versand systems zu
erforschen das freunden helfen konnte
miteinander in kontakt zu bleiben nach
einer zufälligen begegnung mit williams
glaubte er seine chance erkannt zu haben
zu diesem zeitpunkt musste ich mir einen
richtigen job suchen und habe ein
lebenslauf geschrieben ich bin ein sehr
einfacher programmierer und habe diesen
aspekt immer ging aber ich wollte etwas
anderes machen und ich hatte von einem
anderen blogger von ebner fahren beim
mittagessen auf einem kinderspielplatz
beschrieb dorsey die idee die er seit
seiner jugend mit sich herumtrug
das einfachste was wir tun können ist
von meinem handy aus eine nachricht zu
verschicken die andere leute in echtzeit
lesen können er drängte williams dazu in
das ausprobieren zu lassen und sagte
lasst es uns machen das ist so leicht zu
programmieren dass wir es wohl in zwei
tagen schaffen können
williams gab ihm zwei wochen zeit
keystone darum ihm bei der entwicklung
der grafiken und visuelle elemente zu
helfen zwei wochen später hatten sie was
wir haben ein system aufgestellt mit dem
wir sofort eine nachricht verfassen
konnten damit konnte man mit einem 20
dollar nokia handy eine nachricht
schreiben dass man gerade mitten im
central park in new york city ist und
gänse auf dem see vorbeiziehen sieht und
die nachricht würde sofort an alle
freunde in echtzeit verschickt werden am
21 märz 2006 verschickte die erste
nachricht
das produkt funktioniert aber das
freundschafts system brauchte einen
einprägsamen namen
noah glass einer der mitbegründer von
oreo durchforstete das oxford english
dictionary und stieß auf twitter kurze
information aus hofe beziehungsweise
gezwitscher von vögeln das passte
perfekt und es war genau das was wir
machten
williams kaufte sich bei audio aus und
gründete ein neues unternehmen das im
april 2007 zu twitter wurde das kostete
ihn zwei millionen dollar in sagte zu
mir dass wir einfach nicht glauben
würden dass wir hiermit ein geschäft
machen könnten und anstatt allgäuer geld
auszugeben und zu versuchen etwas neues
zu erfinden oder das rad weiter zu
drehen werde ich euch einfach euer geld
zurück und tatsächlich haben viele der
leute mit denen ich in odeo investiert
hatte ihr geld zurückbekommen wer damals
nicht in twitter investiert hat die
verfolgtes bis heute
vorstandsvorsitzender stone war kreativ
direktor und der wortkarge jack dorsey
war der erste ceo von twitter
er will dachte eine zeit lang darüber
nach und kam dann zu dem schluss dass
jack die logische wahl als video wäre er
hatte keine erfahrungen irgendetwas
außer in der codierung er war keine
führungspersönlichkeit und so war es
durchaus ein wagnis ihn zum
geschäftsführer zu machen
[Musik]
es war dieses musikfestival das twitter
zum durchbruch verhalf das jährliche
south by southwest music and technology
festival in austin texas brachte twitter
in 2007 die nötige öffentlichkeit
twitter
[Musik]
ich möchte mich bei allen bedanken in
140 zeichen oder weniger ich habe es
gerade geschafft danke
wir haben zwei bildschirme gemietet sie
in den fluren aufgestellt und darüber
anzeigen lassen was die leute über south
by southwest zusagen halten
wir twitter bei diesem festival zum
ersten mal in freier wildbahn
beobachteten sahen wir wie die leute zu
einer einheit verschmolzen und wir haben
diese idee eines spaßigen festivals
weitergesponnen was wäre wenn das bei
anderen veranstaltungen auf der ganzen
welt der fall wäre twitter hatte seinen
höhepunkt erreicht während des festivals
verdreifachten sich die abgesetzten
tweets von 20.000 auf 60.000 tweets pro
tag
später tauchte zu einer zeit auf als es
seinen demografischen wandel in der
computer nutzung gab als computer nicht
länger nur produktivitäts werkzeuge
waren sondern soziale werkzeuge über die
man sich mitteilen konnte auf twitter
wurde schnell zu einem tool um
mitzuteilen was ich gerade lese ich
gerade denke wo ich gerade bin bin ich
gerade sehe aber
williams und sein team waren auf diesen
ansturm nicht gut vorbereitet wie
williams später charlie rose zählte wir
hatten in den ersten eineinhalb jahren
eine schreckliche phase in der die seite
auf zusammenbrach und sehr langsam war
und wir brauchten lange um das zu
beheben das hat uns das genick gebrochen
glaube ich
es gab interne spannungen in der firma
dorf sie hatte es als ceo schwer
er bekam keinen respekt weil nicht klar
war wozu dieses produkt überhaupt diente
zum einen hatte er als die eu keine
erfahrung keine wirkliche autorität weil
er immer noch in einer firma arbeitete
die von evan kontrolliert wurde und zum
anderen ein produkt das ständig
abstürzte das einzig gute war dass
twitter ordentlich abgehängt
der druck wuchs am 16 oktober 2008
lockte williams dass das unternehmen
eine fokussierte herangehensweise einer
einzigen führungskraft benötige der
ursprüngliche erfinder dort trat als ceo
zurück und williams übernahm jack war am
boden zerstört denn twitter war genau
das worüber check in gewisser weise sein
ganzes leben nachgedacht hatte aus dem
unternehmen gedrängt zu werben war
einfach niederschmetternd er brauchte
monate lang um sich davon zu erholen
twitter befand sich auf jedermanns radar
und das schloss einen sehr
interessierten potenziellen konkurrenten
es sah so aus als würde facebook an den
rand gedrängt werden
twitter war eine internationale
sensation
allein in einem jahr stieg die zahl der
abonnenten der social networking und
microblogging website um mehr als 1300
prozent wie gehen sie mit all der
aufmerksamkeit rund um twitter um
das hat die aufmerksamkeit des facebook
gründers mark zuckerberg erregt
ich habe das gefühl dass magdeburg
wahrscheinlich eine vision hatte wohin
auf facebook bringen will
und er hat wahrscheinlich twitter auf
dem weg zu seiner vision gesehen
zuckerberg versuchte das twitter
geschäft zu übernehmen
business week berichtete dass er 500
millionen dollar in bar und facebook
aktien angeboten hatte was evan williams
ablehnte
bis 2008 kosteten die nutzer 300.000
tweets pro tag
darunter auch oprah winfrey und
dabei sollte es nicht bleiben
[Musik]
bei opera zu sein war nicht so wichtig
wie die aufforderung des
außenministeriums an twitter die
täglichen wartungsarbeiten zu
unterlassen weil die iranischen wahlen
via twitter übertragen wurden
nach dem angeblichen betrug bei den
iranischen wahlen 2009 und gingen die
menschen auf die straße und behörden des
landes zensierten handy nachrichten
zeitungen und websites die über die
zunehmend gewalttätigen protestaktionen
berichteten und damit die traditionelle
nachrichten und den mainstream in den
hintergrund stellte twitter wurde für
die außenwelt so wichtigsten
informationsquelle über den iran wir
mögen keine zensur wir glauben dass der
offene austausch von informationen einen
positiven einfluss auf die ganze welt
haben kann wir waren schon immer für die
gemeinsame nutzung von informationen für
die demokratisierung von informationen
mehr informationen sind besser das
ende 2009 stieg die zahl der tweets auf
zweieinhalb millionen pro tag aber
stephen colbert ließ das kalt
mein gast heute abend ist der
mitbegründer von twitter warum nur 140
zeichen beschreiben zu kompliziert
als limit für texte sind 160 zeichen wir
wollten ein bisschen platz für einen
benutzernamen reservieren also haben wir
140 zeichen festgelegt die kreativität
der kurznachrichten wird sie überraschen
jeder sprach über twitter aber eine
große frage beschäftigte die gründer
immer noch wie machen wir geld ich
glaube nicht dass evan bis toni straße
entlang gehen konnten ohne dass jemand
flüstert wie wollt ihr bitte geld
verdienen wie geht es dieses jahr weiter
auf der ersten entwickler konferenz von
twitter im april 2010 haben die gründer
zum ersten mal einen plan vorgestellt
der aufzeigte wie das unternehmen geld
verdienen könnte wir gehen davon aus
dass die anzeigenschaltung die
gesponserten tweet die wir gerade
starten oder diese woche gestartet haben
in ein paar monaten sicherlich den
größten teil ausmachen werden aber es
wird eine weile dauern sponserte tweets
erlauben es den leuten auf transparente
art und weise botschaften zu
werbezwecken leute zu versenden die
twitter streams folgen und es wird
interessant sein zu sehen wie es
funktioniert ich denke dass das
unternehmen weiß dass es sich um eine
laufende entwicklung handelt am vierten
oktober 2010 kann die nachricht dass
evan williams als ceo des unternehmens
zurücktritt
twitter ist zu einem riesigen
unternehmen herangewachsen und muss sich
trotzdem erst noch als unternehmen
bewähren ich denke dass evan williams
sich nicht als der richtige sei für die
leitung von twitter erwiesen hat
sein nachfolger sollte der ehemalige ceo
dick costolo werden wir wachsen einfach
in einem absurden tempo ich habe schon
ein paar andere unternehmen geleitet und
ein paar jahre bei google verbracht aber
dieses wachstumstempo ist einfach nicht
vergleichbar ich habe noch nie so etwas
gesehen
castello einer der langjährigen
bekannten größen im silicon valley ist
auch wenn der ceo ist immer noch in der
operative gewinn ist ein in denen aber
kein ziel
williams sagte er habe castro gebeten
den job zu übernehmen damit er sich voll
und ganz auf die produktstrategie
konzentrieren könne aber das
stühlerücken entwicklers chefetage ging
im märz 2011 weiter der weggang von
williams öffnete die tür für den
ursprünglichen erfinder jack dorsey der
in eine wichtige rolle zurückkehrte
nämlich als executive chairman
sie twitterte er sei begeistert davon
wieder bei twitter zu arbeiten es ist
ziemlich offensichtlich dass sich die
innovation in den letzten paar jahren
verlangsamt hat und dass twitter zwar
dramatisch gewachsen ist allerdings ohne
sich maßgeblich zu verändern es gab von
anfang an ein problem mit twitter es war
zwar eine wirklich tolle technologie
aber niemand wusste wirklich was diese
für das unternehmen bedeutet das ist ein
problem dass das unternehmen in gewissem
maße bis heute verfolgt aber das hat die
besessenheit der welt von twitter nicht
gezügelt für narzissten ist ein traum
wahr geworden aber auch für journalisten
prominente medienleute marken
buchstäblich für jeden der ein großes
publikum mit einer reihe von nachrichten
erreichen will
peter wirkt sich auf die weltgeschichte
aus es gibt nicht viele unternehmen die
das tun
es steht außer frage dass twitter teil
des gefüges unserer gesellschaft wird
eine art und weise wie menschen
miteinander kommunizieren wie
nachrichten verbreitet werden es ist das
zwitschern von vögeln diese art der
kommunikation werden nicht verstehen und
die doch überaus wichtig ist